see you tomorrow dwight
apparently
how's it going good day not now temp
um
okay
so um listen
i know about
your diabolical plan
what
diabolical plan i wouldn't even know how
to begin a day
i found a copy of it in the copier tray
so what do you want
i want the same thing you want
i want to take jim halpert down
i want in
doom's talking to michael right now they
totally went for our idea yeah
your idea my idea
i just need andy to think it's his idea
so it won't get traced back to me
in approximately six hours jim will get
a phone call from david wallace
he will be fired
okay ladies and gentlemen welcome i know
you're all very excited but no matter
who gets this i just want to say that
you guys are all employees of the month
of my ass
and the winner is
employee number nine and that is number
nine number nine
jim halbert what what are you kidding me
oh no
okay wait
i was not
i did not i
did
guys
listen this was anonymous all right
there's no way i could have given it to
myself because i didn't even know
who was on here i just gave it to the
employee with the highest overall score
to my tally you just won back your own
parking spot a vacation day and a nice
tidy quarter of a thousand dollars from
all of us well everybody just stopped
for a second cause obviously i'm not
taking any of it a mistake has been made
and we'll figure it out second of all
there was no cash prize yes
dwight yeah you said in an ideal world
there would be a cash prize isn't that
what you said no dwight i meant yes in a
perfect world someone would get money
but not but
in your perfect world only you get money
look there was a big mistake obviously
so i will fix it okay
this was your idea anyway correction it
was my idea
okay my idea
good morning everybody
who would like an authentic new york
bagel hmm
stanley thank you oh no no no i got a
pumpernickel just for you
wow h
you went all the way to new york city to
get us bagels
oh why is there a place closer that
sells them this is really nice dwight
thanks thanks oh don't mention it you
owe me one
you all owe me one
good morning michael morning dwight
hungry no i had a fish stick sandwich
actually i had two fish stick sandwiches
my girlfriend didn't want hers because i
guess i'm the only aphrodisiac she needs
fish sticks are not an aphrodisiac yeah
you're thinking of dare penis it worked
regardless that was over two hours ago
and it is now a scientific fact that you
are hungry bagel
i don't mind if i do okay i brought
cheese too i'm taking one for my lady
friend excellent brain food thank you
very much okay
you owe me can a guy just buy some
bagels for his friends so they'll owe
him a favor which he can use to get
someone fired who stole a co-manager
position from him anymore
jeez
when did everyone get so cynical
hi guys uh i just want to say that you
all have been doing amazing work really
thank you and i'd like to add that your
work has been a little sloppy so
dwight and i have implemented a new
program that we like to call
the accountability booster it registers
every time a mistake has been made in
the office from a late delivery to an
accounting error five strikes in a day
equals a home run one home run and
you're out if we as a group make five
mistakes in a day
something bad happens like we block
mindsweeper or in this case an email
gets sent to robert california
containing the consultants report from
last year remember the one that
recommended the branch be shut down and
as a fail-safe also every negative email
you've ever written about him to the
group will also be forwarded to him what
emails are you talking about robert's
favorite songs creep by tlc creep by
radiohead remember that one jim uh
there's no way he hasn't strangled at
least one stripper oscar
he eats his yogurt like he is punishing
it for disappointing him kelly
it's not that bad actually
p.s we should kill him
wait so you installed a doomsday device
no it's an accountability booster which
when it goes off it destroys everything
very similar to a doomsday device jim
you're trying to make me sound like some
kind of evil maniac now the point is is
that we are now working in an
environment where we have accountability
to each other i am confident that you
guys are equal to the task um no we're
not and you are a psycho who is ruining
our lives
we can't do this
this is
they're making me out to be a bond
villain i like to think of myself as a
brilliant scientist who will stop at
nothing to remake the world
like
not dr moreau someone good
dr frankenstein
bobcat this is dragon
listen he's been promoted to soul
manager we've got to step this up meet
me behind the dumpster in 90 seconds
89
58.
you're 20 minutes late
um
i was at another dumpster just admit you
lost track of time
ryan and i have been meeting up to work
on our diabolical plot against jim ryan
is always late for our meetings
i wish i had a lair
did you see saw of course i see saw mos
and i see saw all the time no uh the
movie did you see the movie song oh yeah
great film almost as fun as going on a
see-saw okay the reason these movies are
so popular is the element of
psychological torment
i like where you're going with this
continue
can we lure him into an old warehouse or
something i have an old barn it's kind
of smelly yes but that might be a plus
okay and then what we do what they
didn't saw
i mean we don't kill him obviously i
have a mask
that's your idea exactly like in the
movie
that is the most idiotic thing i've ever
heard in my life well suggest something
else then don't just supposed to cut his
leg off don't just criticize my idea you
think of something then
this conversation has two items on the
agenda did we have a conversation
scheduled number one do not leave your
things on my desk it's not some kind of
personal pen receptacle for you i don't
care how high they promote you which
brings me to item number two
i never formally congratulated you on
your promotion so i'd just like to say
congratulations
wow that's
really thoughtful of you dwight thank
you you're welcome
i inserted a listening device into the
belly of the mallard now i can observe
jim trap jim and destroy jim just like
in the bavarian fairy tale
only this time the mallard skins the
toad alive
and of course in this version you lose
the whole veiled critique of the kaiser
thing
i'm sorry to have been bugging you all
these years
it's a real handsome duck mallard okay
i'll get out of your hair
dwight you brought the mallard back
well i had to i mean kelly was nutty
hi buddy
i'm sorry a wooden duck mallard
i
put it in your office in order to
surveil you
i was jealous that you got the promotion
over me okay just to be clear you're
terrible with this and you're not
equipped for espionage oh i'm equipped
so i can't
don't tell michael no
but you will wash and buff our car
punishment fits the crime i accept
uh we have our high quality 28 pound
bond our heavier 38 pound bond
or ours
i've got eight hours of this
of course i wanted jim to find the
mallard make him feel safe
did you really think i would put my
primary listening device in a wooden
mallard
i'm not insane
65 pound cover stock which is the
heaviest
you